how are y'all
good afternoon thanks for coming out
my name is tom bowers and uh the
attorney for china and her
son junior we would definitely
uh the family wants to thank the entire
city uh for
the uh the amazing support
at dante's funeral and the uh
it's great to see a city coming together
a city
coming together people of all colors and
all races coming out
to show support it does show that there
is hope
for problems that we've been having in
the city and across the nation there's
hope
for those problems to be solved one day
it's a great it's a great feeling to see
that
and to uh support him on those bonus
journeys
and now it's time for us to support him
on this journey to justice
and it's sad that it appears to be
happening over and over again
but hopefully we can get the same
results that uh
read a letter that
she has written that talks about dante
to you all
just right now
um
there's over there on the ground i think
it might be
thanks yeah
my heart breaks for ourselves
[Music]
he scared us
we continue to pray and ask god to heal
him
and he's still here today
i'm sorry we might get to see your
second birthday party
and the fact that somebody took you from
here
this feels like a nightmare only thing
is
it's not a bad dream it's reality
i want you to know no matter what i'll
always love you
don't worry i will make sure baby not to
know
how much you love him and how special he
was in your eyes
he looks just like i am thankful he left
it's too
and i'll never forget
uh you know it's sad to say goodbye to
someone that you love and father
[Music]
family is in pain
a better future for us all i'd also like
to introduce
uh now tiffany gillian's with the
african-american human
rights organization she does a lot of
nonprofit work throughout the nation
and i think he's going to be doing a lot
of work here trying to heal
the wounds of our nation
good evening this is a sad time
and i wish we could be here on other
happy circumstances
the african-american human rights
organization is an organization that
started our dallas and
we basically look at incidences of
police brutality
and police violence against
uh minorities especially in the african
american communities
um
eventually end up being killed kids
and that statistic is actually from the
proceedings of the national academy
of police house we've got to do a better
job
we talked about it and the pandemic but
right now we're in the middle of
everything and that is um
there's an epidemic on the minority
community an epidemic of police violence
and police brutality
it has to be addressed and it has to be
stopped and we can't do it by ourselves
it's going to take more than just
african-americans
to band together and say that this is a
problem right
you're going to have to have the help
the results of the george boyd uh
verdict shows that not only did
african-americans
see that something had gone wrong with
george floyd entertainment but that
other nationalities
that were on the jury saw that something
had gone hard as well
and once we can admit that there is a
problem in our police department there's
a problem with
training there's a problem with white
supremacists being recruited
as police officers
um
thank you for your time
i kind of mentioned it earlier the
journey for justice
now that uh dante is on his journey home
to our father now we can begin to try to
get justice for him
and i want to make sure i judgment i
also addressed a few things that the
family had concerns about
one of them i think there's a police
organization here in the state
that said that if he would apply dante
then he'd be alive you know and i can't
think of any other statement it's a
pretty uh horrible statement to say
somebody passes away because everyone is
innocent
and still proven guilty to what we'd
like to think right
and you know police officers aren't
executioners
you know so my job is just beginning our
job is just beginning as a people to
make sure that people get a good process
people like dante get through process
and that it doesn't happen to anyone
else's time so
it's time to
send the officer that killed him to jail
and let justin speak up and to also
touch on that like they touched on
yesterday at the funeral
change the laws and put things in place
to make sure that we can we can save our
youngsters
okay because you know
like i said everybody deserves due
process and it's almost like
you know you're looking at executions
now you're looking at modern day
mentions
that are gone on account you know
strange fruit right and it's really
disturbing it's almost numbing
when you see the verdict come out as an
african-american i was not
you kind of expect that it won't go the
right way
but when it does you really don't know
how to react because you're not used to
getting fair play but uh
it it is something that gives us
a breath of fresh air a sigh of relief
to be able to see
finally things turning out different
set of officers walking free
so the new day is dawning
and i want to keep it brief if you have
any questions
moving forward for me then i can answer
some of those on behalf of the family
i don't want to specifically point those
out there are some security concerns
uh you know whenever you have an event
like this you get a lot of people
come out and america is an interesting
place
so there are some concerns about safety
for the family that we're addressing
and making sure that
and i'm not sure you know why that
happens but you know you do have people
who
support the officer no matter no matter
what and some people
you know are happy that she you know
that she killed dante i'll just be
honest with you
so i always get a bunch of calls and
emails that are
that are pretty uh racist
and that's it's a sad thing to see that
you know or you'll see comments on
social media that are bad
or that they're nasty or like like
whatever police organization here in the
state said hey he complied that
he'd still be alive i mean who says that
when a mother
has just lost her child you know i mean
i don't know
sometimes it seems like people don't
have hearts but yes there have been
some threats to the family and this is
disturbing but hopefully
are you happy with the prosecution now
some community groups are wanting the
attorney general's office to step in and
prosecute is that something the family
would like
well uh i i i like to see them moving
pretty fast to do things that are right
instead of in other years where they
they don't release the tapes you know
they
they have a smear campaign on the uh
the victim so it's good to see that they
are
they're listening to the people of all
colors who were disturbed in the city i
saw people of all colors out there with
batters
and waving at the procession
so i do like to see positive things
happening and i'm seeing some positive
things in the state
toward justice and they're making sure
that trials are held in
their fair trials and that these
officers
when they execute somebody in the street
that they're held accountable
so i do like to see that obviously you
know so hopefully we can get these laws
changed
to stop the minor traffic stops from
turning into a death sentence
you know or modern-day lynching you know
you still
you still got it but it's just a
different form
[Music]
the charge so far is manslaughter i
believe it's second degree manslaughter
there's been some calls for um for a
tougher charge
do you support does the family support
well the family supports a fair and
thorough investigation
and for the uh prosecutors to take a
really good uh
good look at this and do a really good
investigation so not just taking her
maybe talking to other witnesses to see
where her state of mind is and
see if maybe there's a different intent
i'm not a criminal law lawyer
in this state but i i do understand that
you've got to do a thorough
investigation to see
if there is a more appropriate charge
you can't just rest the justice
but you can't just you can't not do your
job and do a thorough investigation
either
so it's hard to know what the intent of
a
police officer is but you know even
it doesn't take a rocket scientist to
look at that video
and tell that she may have known that
she had her blood instead of her taser
in her hand
right that just doesn't make any sense
or you know i haven't investigated all
the facts but from what i'm hearing if
you're a
trainer for 20 years it sounds to me
like you know better than
you know if you have your gun at the
taser in your hand just kind of common
sense
right so we'll leave it up they've done
a good job on george floyd they've got
good results on that
so i would trust i think the family
trust that they'll do a good job on this
and come to the
come to a fair conclusion that's all
[Music]
you've got a jury disappears that jury
finds that she is guilty then that would
give the family some sentiments
china and her
lawsuit i think uh that's always
uh you know i'm a lawyer so obviously
a civil lawsuit is something that we do
to to get justice
you can't bring them back you know i
would do anything to bring them back too
if i could i'd like to go home you know
today
and they wouldn't have to bring us to a
lawsuit so it may be something that we
do but we will try to open a dialogue
with the city of the police department
to see if there's some sort of
revolution that can come before that
because it's it's painful for a family
to have to not only go to the funeral
and see him there playing here
lifeless that's painful it's even more
painful to have to relive this
every single day not just up until the
trial of the verdict but after that as
well
you know it's painful and people forget
african-americans feel pain too
they love their loved ones they love
their children they want their children
to grow up to be
successful so
whatever we can do to get a resolution
and get justice for them
could we ask just a few questions i
don't think she wants to ask
answer any questions she let me know
that uh before we came out here
but the family just wants to thank
everybody everybody for their support
and the love that they showed at the
funeral
and the love that the majority of people
are showing
uh his life and his child
and the outpouring of support nationwide
mostly it's been mostly positive you've
got a few
negative things but
and you can see that there is hope for a
brighter future
where you know everyone of all colors
can get due process on the street it
won't get executed
and and live a full life
could you qualify to date just now how
much support and donations china has now
received
oh i'm not sure about that but i know
she has received
an outpouring of support from churches
and individuals
because now you know her uh her son's
father's dead there's no one financially
to make sure he can go to college to
make sure he can go to prom
and make sure he can do those things
that children do
when they grow up so a it's a very uh
amazing thing to see we've come a long
way as a nation i think we'll
we'll get there one day is there
anything that you want done
with that executive director of the
police officers federation that made the
comment on the radio
is there wanting to step down well i
think the police officers
uh i think police officers and people in
those positions have got to be careful
what they say they're they're supposed
to be guys
behold the ball you know you're not
supposed to show any animosity
toward you know anyone you're not
supposed to make statements like that
you're supposed to do your job and to
say if he complied
and he'd be alive you're basically
saying that we've got a right to execute
you
when we want to right everyone's
innocent until proven guilty
and you know as a lawyer and as citizens
we've got to keep fighting until that's
the case
you know that's basically it we just got
to keep fighting we're all in this
together with taxpayers
and as taxpayers they work for us we pay
their salary
so we deserve better service than that
right
so maybe something should be done they
need to look into that
i'm not sure if he's a police officer or
et cetera sarah but i know one police
officer donated
to someone's fund and got dismissed i
guess he donated to
someone who had done something bad kyle
whitman house fund
some police officer did something like
that and they got removed or he got
recommended for it
so uh police officers are held to a
higher standard just like me
you know so uh just like i am just like
a judge is
if we're doing something that's bad or
we're making statements that we're not
supposed to make
we can we can get admonished for that so
maybe something
you know i don't see his name i don't
know his name i'm not trying to debate
anybody but i heard that there was a
statement that was made
that was insensitive at worst
you know and you know anyway
but when do you in terms of this like a
possible civil lawsuit
you just maybe just talk about your
thought process like you would make a
decision
on that would you wait for the criminal
you know well there are a lot of lawyers
in play
on this case i think i think the other
family has quite a few lawyers over
there obviously you saw some lawyers
speaking at the funeral the other day
so strategically from that point
sometimes we speak together to figure
out the best
avenue to move forward because we don't
want to jeopardize the case
by different lawyers doing different
things so obviously we communicate with
each other
and we want to open a dialogue with the
uh
the city and the police department and
any other possible defendant
to see if there's some sort of
resolution that we could reach
outside of putting the family through
all that pain and causing them
all that expense so have you started
have you started the dialogue
not yet the funeral just happened
yesterday
so i would imagine we'll start that
pretty soon try to sit down and
not only to figure out what to do with
this case but to figure out how to
prevent this from happening
again i think that needs to be done
obviously that would be with brooklyn
brooklyn center no so i haven't reached
out yeah
okay
uh with the right family are you in
communication with them about this or
not
yet well i just met them the other day
okay so uh we will be at communication
it's kind of it's it's a it's a common
thing for lawyers to
communicate even though they represent
different people
uh concerning the same matter
because you don't want to you don't want
to fight you know amongst each other
you'd like to work together to see if
you can get justice
do you like singing and spelling your
name i'm sorry thomas bowers
bowers were the best i think i saw
well i'd like to thank everybody for
coming out uh again the family
wishes to thank the entire city uh for
showing their support and moving forward
also showing that support
in their uh journey for justice for
dante wright
and hopefully y'all have a good evening
if you have any questions feel free to
call me
i've always failed thank you overall
oh that wants to say something
hello my name is renee russo um
i'm one of five dance um
i'm the great head of dante wright jr
[Music]
teen um sometimes that relationship
falls apart
however they feel good friends
co-parenting and still care for one
another
um they had a son
dante uh wright junior
he was a premier he was born one pound
12
hold him in your hand so we weren't sure
how his life was going to be because
he'd been preparing me and being severe
um he overcome things would still come
from that
speaking of dante's senior he was a good
father devoted dedicated
supporter of his son in china
i know in relationships
being a single mom it's difficult
but being a senior mom without a father
is even worse
he will never have that time that
father's son time
playing ball going to the games
dead son talks when it comes to girls
and learning to be a man but
i can assure dante
senior that we will take care of him
we will love him be supportive of his
son
show him love he'll have love on both
sides of the family
[Music]
um
it's just going to be difficult for
china as being a single parent
and not having her father there um
because dante was involved
i think we'll help out with that right
there
but unfortunately his life was ended
sooner than we expected never
anticipated that
even with we were talking same with
dante
the other day and some he just looked up
and he said daddy
and it was touching because
god works in the steers ways and i think
maybe that was the spirit coming down
uh the scholar from the sun um
i don't know but i i i trust and believe
that's what
i just want china to know you have the
love of your family
and there's nothing to do
and we'll do whatever we can to support
her and help dante jr grow up
to be healthy not be careful of
being in a vehicle because he's black
so hopefully with things the way it is
and
and um the recent case
uh uh george glory that things will
change
for the betterment where we can walk and
work and live
in peace and not be threatened or
intimidated or fearful of
police or anyone you know
so i just wanted to say that and again
china's a step-father there safety works
it's a tragic event what happened to
with dante
and move on justice devante and
to seek justice but let don taste bob
because he's gonna have to grow up
without his father
and it's the rules that i'm gonna have
to play
is his others i'm gonna have to play
because everybody's gonna be
a vital instrument in his life right now
and he needs all the support
and all the encouragement that he can
receive
and it's a sad fact when
when people and i when we have police
that ponies our community
when they shoot down a 20 year old
a child you know take another just
taking the life
this is it's not a good thing you know
especially unjustly for no
for no apparent reason and now not only
the parents suffering
the the children have so his son have to
suffer
his baby mama have to suffer the
a tragic loss for nothing
and it's sad and someone need to pay for
that
because it all is suffering that the
family is doing like i said i feel that
the city
should pay for that tragedy that they
inflicted on his family
and we got to speak together we're going
to come together and we're going to get
all the support that we need because
it's
it's sad it's very sad
and like i said some of the statements
that was made in this case it shouldn't
have been made
you know i mean the officer was wrong no
no ain't no
ain't no question to that and the city
shouldn't question that the officer was
wrong
and they should have been dealt with it
a different way should have went about
it at a different way
and we will see we want justice without
tape we want their justice for little
we want justice for china we want
justice place parents
and we demand justice
we demand justice for dante right we
demand
justice for lead on tape because now he
hasn't grown without a father
so we all have to play father his
grandfather got to be a father his
father's got to be a father his uncles
his brothers
everybody have to be fathers in this
life now because he don't need that
support
because because they took away his
father
and his mother and his mother suffering
she had to wake up every day with her
son
knowing that he'd never see his father
again and it's painful to it
and i hate to see myself go to suffer
the way she does because it bothers her
you know to know that her son is not
gonna ain't gonna be able to wake up to
his father
and when his father gonna have many
questions mama where's my dad
[Music]
he's right we should all as american
citizens demand
that should be our crowd
with nation demand justice for anyone
that's
at the hand of injustice receive any
sort of injustice
behavior or treatment demand justice
but if anybody doesn't have any more
questions
i'd like to thank everybody for coming
out listening to
[Music]
china's family and realize that it's not
just
that everybody's hurt not only do you
have a community that's hurt
you've got a family that's
that's that's broken and that may never
heal
you know forever and it's something that
could been prevented
and there's gotta be small things that
we can do as a community to make sure
that this doesn't happen again
if we work together speak out and do
what we can do
as individuals and as citizens and as
human beings
in some areas so thanks again hopefully
everyone has a good
and safe evening and i appreciate y'all
coming out
thank you
you